les deux départements alsaciens ont
finalement été décrétées en situation de
catastrophe naturelle hier au total ce
sont 69 départements français concernés
ces arrêtés seront publiés aujourd'hui
au journal officiel de quoi favoriser
peut-être les indemnisations
alors que la situation est en passe de
redevenir normale en alsace le point
avec grégory fraises l'alsace commence à
retrouver une situation à peu près non
les départements comme partie des 69
décrétées en situation de catastrophe
naturelle cette classification devrait
faciliter les déclarations aux
assurances et les indemnisations pour
beaucoup elle ne changera pas
grand-chose ne sont en effet concerner
que les dégâts causés par les
inondations les coulées de boue et les
mouvements de terrain les autres dégâts
restent couverts par les assureurs à
travers la garantie tempête
les assurés bénéficient d'un délai
exceptionnel le déclaration de bijoux
aujourd'hui la situation s'améliore donc
encore le trafic était normal
ce pari dévié par
c'est urgent et sur les routes où une
quarantaine de départements défavorisés
qui est le reste du réseau
dans le coup de coude
ce pack est disponible et old harry
du côté de la fée électricité moins de
5000 foyers en sont encore privés dans
le bas-rhin 28 communes haut-rhinoises
comme est encore des perturbations des
techniciens travaillent d'arrache-pied
et 10,6 en bar le franc et châtenois par
bamba électricien allemand du bade
wurtemberg de façon bénévole
ils prêtent mains tracas des aides pour
établir la bassila aux pensions c'est
aussi grâce à ce genre d'actions
solidaires que l'alsace a pu si
rapidement sortir la tête de l'eau